Speaker 1: Let's go next to Kevin from San
Diego.
Kevin, welcome.
Speaker 3: Hey, David.
How's it going?
It's going well.
I was not expecting you.
Call me.
I was, like, busy with playing video games.
All right.
Well, yeah, so.
I guess I'm still.
I'm still wondering, like, what is what is
going to happen with this this Trump execution
of a search warrant because it was not actually
a raid?
Is have we have we found anything more out
about what's going on with that?
Speaker 1: In what sense?
Find out more.
And what do you mean?
Like, is are there going to be charges, that
type of thing?
Speaker 3: Well, I mean, the latest thing
that I heard was that there was Trump was
looking after getting the what was it, the
affidavit?
Yeah.
It released to everyone, which I think Pat
was saying on like Monday or something, you
know, that could backfire on on Trump if that's
something.
But we don't really know what's in that affidavit
yet.
Yeah, I don't know.
I'm just I'm wondering how how all of that's
going to how that's going to shake out.
Speaker 1: If it does.
And we don't we don't know yet.
There's a couple of different things that
might happen if it sort of evaporates and
nothing happens and there's no charges and
it just kind of fades.
The narrative from the right will be this
was unnecessary and outrageous and meant to
humiliate Trump, and they will have a case
that that case will feel very strong if that's
the case, because this is a big step to take.
It was a completely legal step.
They they crossed all the I's and dotted all
the T's, as Sean HANNITY said.
But if if nothing happens to do this to a
president is a big step.
So that's one possibility.
And that will probably strengthen the right.
Beyond that, there's a number of other possible
scenarios whose timing, you know, is it before
or after the midterms?
Is it a before after Trump potentially declares
his candidacy for 24?
There's just too many unknowns right now to
say.
Speaker 3: Yeah.
I mean, I am really I want it to be something
where I see having like the affidavit get
released but like redacted any kind of people's
names that would be.
Potentially targets of right wing extreme
people going after them.
I think that would be good because having
something that like sort of proves like, yeah,
Trump does have somebody that's in his organization
that basically sold him out and told them
that there was there was all these documents.
Speaker 1: That that would be, I think, the
potentially most damaging thing that could
come from the affidavit, which is the confirmation
that there is a sort of mole or traitor which
has been speculated but not proven.
Speaker 3: Yeah, but then again, that also
comes with the the downside of if the mole
or traitor is revealed, but it's not redacted,
then like that person's going to be everybody
is going to go be going after them like, yeah,
them going after Bruce Wayne and The Dark
Knight returns.
Speaker 1: Which I don't want.
I want people to be safe.
So.
Speaker 3: Yeah, yeah, that would be bad.
Speaker 1: Well, let's give it another couple
of weeks and see where we are, you know, around
mid-September.
Speaker 3: Yes.
I'm sorry.
All right.
Speaker 1: Thank you for the call very much.
Appreciate it.
We're going to take the quickest of breaks,
but don't hang up because then we're going
right back to the discord lines and we're
going to hear from more people.
So just stand by.
We will be right back with more
of
your calls.